My name is Noah Planavsky, and I'm a geochemist.
Where a lot of my research is focused right now
is trying to understand what controls carbon dioxide levels
and how we can change carbon dioxide levels over the next 100 years to have greater climate stability.
I originally went to school as a geologist and I thought I was going to
wander Earth's surface just making observations
in the rock record.
But I found that most of the questions
that I was interested in
were better solved through geochemical tools
and through geochemical modeling
than field observations alone.
The type of geochemistry that I do is understanding how individual reactions
occurring in organisms within soil or within
the ocean
will affect the atmosphere, will affect climate on a global scale.
For me, what's going to be the next step
in geochemistry
and what's going to make geochemistry more impactful
is the core of my research program,
which is a better integration of field observations,
novel geochemical tools, and tying that into a robust
and meaningful quantitative framework.
Of course, it makes sense
to have all of those components combined.
Having a research program
that does that well
and that ensures that all of those parts are greater
than what they would be individually
is I think what's going to be
the important component of moving forward
our understanding over the next decade.